so I had a lot of people I've been doing
go now for for almost five years now and
during that time I've shown up at a lot
of usually a lot of Ruby me that's
telling everybody use go which by the
way is really mean don't do that like
don't go to other people's meetups and
tell them that they're doing it wrong I
do that that's my job if you start doing
that I'm out of business that's their
good but I'd show up and these people
would say okay mark you love go what do
you use to build web apps I said well
you just use rails and I'm like well
that seems counterintuitive to your
statement of go is amazing and it is but
this was me honestly up until this year
and then this happened Buffalo the the
question is where's the logo came first
or not it did now so yeah well let's
talk about Buffalo buffalo is an
ecosystem for rapid web development is
it a framework you might say that I
won't because the framework is where it
is taboo in our industry for some reason
or at least this community the word
framework is like a kiss of death for
some reason I was talking to Steve again
about this is an IDE Steve wrote Cobra
who uses Cobra right it's excellent
it's excellent but you know what it is
it's a framework and Steve said that
when he first published Cobra it was
like why would you need this framework
just to use the standard library we have
the flags package it's like well if you
ever tried to build a complicated CLI
tool using just a standard library kind
of hard not gonna lie to you
so Buffalo I like to consider an
ecosystem cuz it's not just about the
Buffalo package matter of fact the
Buffalo package itself is not overly big
and that's important to remember what it
is is glue around the best parts of go
and the best parts of what the community
has had to offer for go we take the
stance of we'd rather not have to write
it ourselves we want to use the gorilla
Lux rudder that is battle tested and
everybody loves right I don't want to
ride a router you don't want me to
Reimer I can't even say right around her
well I said at that time maybe I can
build her out or who knows buffalo takes
all this stuff and just kind of gives it
to you we found the best packages and
I'll talk about some of them in a minute
to do all these things for you
so that you can roll an app out in a
weekend and those people coming to go
for the first time can have that
positive experience that welcoming
experience that they had the first time
they went through rails for example I
remember going from Java to Rails back
in 2005 actually fun fact I quit Java in
2003
I quit development I rage quit
development after writing a hundred
thousand lines of XML and it's not a
joke
hundreds of XML I rage quit and worked
in a recording studio for two years that
was I was and then I was out and then
someone introduced me to rails and it
was magical it was like oh look how
welcoming this is like I can get
something out fast
and that's what I want I want to just
start coding I don't want to spend time
figuring out all these pieces right as a
consultant as a business owner as a
human being I need to just get to market
I just want to get my stuff out there I
don't want to spend weeks rolling my own
custom router or my own templating
system or figuring out my how to run
migrations against my database I want
somebody to figure that all out for me
somehow I became that person which is
kind of terrible this is an important
slide and one I really want to drive
home when we talk about Buffalo buffalo
is extracted it is not imagined and that
is important whenever you're talking to
anybody about their new framework their
new library their new tool if they
imagine if they sat down one day and
said you know it would be nice a package
a library or framework to do X Y & Z
don't use it because it hasn't been used
it hasn't been tested someone yes who
was it was it Matt was it you yesterday
who said like um just hold on to it like
don't release anything publicly like
play with it learn it right and then you
can release it publicly and that's what
happened buffalo buffalo
is years old in a lot of ways and I
spent a year working for a company
building an enterprise application for
them that needed to be installed on-site
they needed they didn't know what the
database was gonna be so they needed
support from MySQL PostgreSQL light they
need to feel a ship a binary no other
files no templating files no JavaScript
files a single binary they need to be
able to send it to them and say here
here a couple commands and that binary
run them and that's where buffalo really
took shape and then in December of last
year I was talking with Brian Kedleston
and I can't remember how the
conversation came up I said I'll let me
show you something and I showed him
buffing he's like oh my god you
absolutely have to open source that you
need to publish that and then he
scheduled me on go time like for two
weeks later you get two weeks yeah two
weeks to bang this thing into shape and
that's true and his that up did anybody
is anybody heard my go time episode
couple people yeah you you more of you
should because it is the highest-rated
go time episode it is and it's live from
a Dunkin Donuts which has a story to it
but anyway buffalo has two goals and the
first one is incredibly selfish I'm not
gonna lie to you it's let me write
applications as fast as I can i rails
that is a hundred percent the first goal
I consider myself to be the primary user
of buffalo actually I consider Brian
cattle son to be the primary user
Buffalo is I think you push more
production Buffalo helps and I have you
write one a week I think at this point
yeah
but for me that was the original impetus
right I want to be able to write apps as
fast like Hana rails the other ones bit
more altruistic I want to make go more
accessible and I think the web is the
best place to do that and why do I think
that I think well I know there are more
web developers in the world than anybody
else well not anybody else there's a lot
of Chinese people
probably more of them than men web
developers I'm almost positive that I'll
check later but now there are more web
developers than any other type of
developers that's probably a better
qualification and that's a big world
we've got between 500 and $100,000
he double that triple that by bringing
in people from other communities who are
used to writing these web apps we can
pull those rails folks in matter of fact
someone the other day on Twitter said I
was just about to give up on golang and
then I found Buffalo and it's almost
like a conspiracy to make rails or as
Gophers I was like no it's a conspiracy
that's absolutely the point we want to
get more people and go because I want a
bigger community
I want conferences like this to thrive
and we're seeing this we're seeing more
and more conferences every single year
which is awesome but we can make this
thing go through the roof
and what do we get with a bigger
community apart from more information
and more diversity and better libraries
and better packages we get more jobs who
here writes go full-time for their
current job not enough people right not
enough people and you know why because
we need more go developers if you have
more go developers companies will take
more of a risk on go and it's not really
risk as we know go is amazing you're not
here to be sold on go you're already
paid for your ticket or you stumbled in
off the street Ernesto but yeah
companies will be take more of a chance
and they'll say okay look look at all
these developers out there and they're
all doing these amazing things we should
start doing that in-house so more jobs
bigger community means more jobs means
less not writing go and that's awesome I
am down to one rails app one ruby app I
have to maintain unfortunately no I'd
love to I love the app but I want to
write it in Buffalo but it's three years
old I can't but I'm down to that and
that's an awesome feeling to not have to
deal with Ruby anymore nothing against
Ruby but I really love go so really what
better way to grow go I think then
through the web so with that said enough
evangelizing why I think
Buffalo is important to the community
hopefully you feel the same way
hopefully you you can see that as a
community we can take this project and
it's not my project we've got a lot of
great contributors and I want to see
more contributors but we can take this
thing and we can make it big and we can
grow this community in a way that's you
know we've only just kind of touched the
surface on so that's the why of Buffalo
if you will let's talk about the what
it's probably what some of you were here
to see but what of Buffalo buffalo is a
batteries included framework and we've
heard this phrase before but when I say
batteries included I actually mean all
of the batteries not just the go
batteries and that's an important part
of what Buffalo does here are some of
the included batteries for example
gorilla mocks for routing plush for
templating pop for database web pack and
yarn for our asset pipeline deployment
we've got things like docker and Buffalo
build which we'll talk about testing we
got go we got some testify in their task
scripting if you ever used like a rake
in Ruby before we got an amazing system
called grift which lets you use the
phrase I ran a grift today no okay so I
named things based on puns never mind
okay internationalization sessions the
whole nine yards if you don't like the
included batteries that's fine just use
your own there's only one included
battery that is absolutely required
that's the gorilla mocks router but if
you you know so that's the only one you
absolutely have to use but if you don't
like your own use the other way you get
rid of them a lot of these have flags so
just turn them off you don't want
webpack turn it off you don't want
docker turn it off
you don't want plush or templating and
use the API flag and boom you're just
dealing with JSON stuff right there's
lots of lots of customization here we're
not forcing you to use anything except
for gorilla mocks but with that said
understand that if you change out some
of these pieces some of the built-in
generators may not work for you as I
kind of have expectations of what you're
expecting to do but for example and I
don't expect you to read this code you
can replace the templating engine by
implementing
the template engine type just one
function takes three arguments you can
create your own renderers it's one func
it's a interface with two functions very
simple functions and so on and so forth
let's talk about development what's the
development time like for me buffalo is
all about developer productivity that is
the number one metric I base Buffalo on
how easy can I build my app how fast can
I build my app I go into an argument
with somebody on github the other day
because they wanted benchmarks on like
the router and stuff like it so the
gorilla mucks wrote go look at their
benchmarks and you're like but we've
what are you diving on top I'm like does
it matter you get to millisecond
response times it doesn't matter it's
fast enough for you for me the
development speed is the benchmark that
matters and we'll do this I'm actually
gonna build an app and we'll deploy it
to Heroku by the end of this talk here
we offer a ton of commands buffalo is
not just a package it is a tool chain
and that's why I say it's an ecosystem
the Buffalo binary has so many sub
commands and so many sub commands off
those sub commands so do insane things
now we have plugins where you can write
your own sub commands for Buffalo and
plug them in and we'll see that with my
Heroku one later but the Buffalo dev
command compiles starts the application
for you watches any assets and rebuilds
them if you're using webpack so as you
change your style sheets and JavaScript
and by the way its default configuration
is es6 and s CSS and jQuery and all its
stuff is gonna ready out of the box we
do production minification ugly fiying
and stuff like that for you static
assets to serve from disks there's no
recompiling of go file like you know if
you heard you sing like go bin data
before we have to keep compiling every
time you make a change to something we
don't have to do that they're all served
from disk until later if your go files
change we watch them we recompile the
application and restart it for you so
the by the time you hit save and them
and you tab back over to your browser
your apps already restarted you can
refresh the page and there your changes
we even show you a web page if there was
an error compiled in your binary and
tell you what the error is we go out of
our way to make the developer experience
amazing for you
deployments this is another key thing we
want to be able to deploy our apps
quickly and fast one of my favorite ways
is docker and if you generate a new
Buffalo app for example you get a file
that looks like this it's a multi-stage
docker file and that's all you need to
compile and deploy your application or
you can use the Buffalo build command
which is kind of cool too again builds
assets for production if you're using
webpack bundles your templates your
assets your migrations anything else any
other static content you might have into
the binary all there in one command auto
versions the binary installs the SHA and
the build time into the binary as well
so we can query the binary we can run
migrations off the binary we can serve
the app off the binary that's kind of an
important one
it supports all to go tags LD Flags
environment variables everything like
that entire tool chain is one binary to
rule them all
now whatever you know I don't want to be
here either we just tell the organizers
we had a talk and enough okay let's do a
little demo shall we so for our demo
we're going to bring up someone from EA
to demo their really boring game for the
next ten minutes so let's start a new
application here so petals' ins name
just popped up bigger how's that okay so
there we go its the buffalo new command
all apps start with a buffalo new and
you can see we've got a ton of flags
here to skip yarn skip webpack skip pop
docker you can do non multi standard
database type Postgres MySQL sequel Lite
you can skip that entirely you can do
just the API which makes it just aged
like JSON API and get sort of all
templating and fun stuff like that I
don't know why you would but you could
but let's create a new Buffalo app here
called golang UK that sounds good
here we go this is gonna go get a few
things go import step oh we have a
console in Buffalo
so your New Buffalo console and get in
there and you can talk to your models
and stuff like that which is kind of fun
and the console is getting a big rewrite
as well we're not gonna keep using Gore
we're gonna we've got a big rewrite in
the works here so now I'm gonna
installed a bunch of front end packages
here there we go I've created my whole
application I've created a ton of files
I've actually done a get in it and if I
go into the application here was it
golang UK not go lonk there we go can't
type standing up why they make people
types anyhow this is what your default
Buffalo application looks like hard to
read in the back but you shouldn't sat
in the back plenty of space up front I
don't know why you'd be back there yeah
we've got a couple dot files here but
we've got actions this world our
handlers are gonna go this is how we're
gonna handle all of our requests our
assets is where our style sheets are
Java scripts are s CSS our images
whatever we want to go in there are
Griff's these are these little tasks we
get to run here locales for
internationalization models for our
database stuff node modules because it's
node I don't know what they do they put
stuff in there don't look it's scary
public folders of all your assets gets
compiled and then templates that's where
all of our templates ago so first thing
I like to do well the first thing I
usually do well I don't do because I'm
awesome
he's configure my database yeah Mel file
to talk to my database make sure that's
it's set up correctly so if we look at
that here for me this is 100% set up
correctly surprised it works fine on my
machine but yeah you can figure your
username your password your hosts all
that sort of stuff and once you've done
that you can run the nice DB create -
all command they rego I've created my
production development and test
databases
all created for me I could start my
application here there we go it started
on port 3000 and if I go to port 3000 my
assets ever compiled there we go
a buffalo fantastic be pretty boring if
that was it that wouldn't it be but this
is kind of interesting I love this
feature this is just the homepage but we
can show this on the console too I'll
actually show it on console X I think
it's cooler there Buffalo tasks routes
here we go here's a list of all of our
routes method get' slash there no
aliases for this route the helper name
that you can use in your templates
there's route path and this is the
handler that's hacked actually handling
that which is kind of cool so I can just
very simply look and say who is handling
that particular thing and it gives me
the actual like full path name to it but
you won't see in a lot of other places
okay so we've got an app running here
but that's not that interesting let's
actually do something here let's uh do
some database stuff shall we yeah I love
I love your enthusiasm you like yes mark
let's create a new resource and we'll
call this widget and widget will have a
name and it'll have a body which is of
type text if I run that there we go I've
created a whole bunch of code I've
created actions an entire set of crud
actions to handle my resource I've said
it created a whole entire set of
templates to handle my resource I have
also created models to handle my
resource I have created migrations to
handle my resource and now I can run
Buffalo DB migrate there we go I've
created my database it's my table in my
database and we if we go back here and
restart there we go
starts up everything here I go back ok
now I have a whole bunch of widgets
stuff in my routing table if you don't
believe me that that actually exists and
we'll look at some of this code in a
second
here here we go here's my widgets and I
create a new widget and if I hit save
ooh I didn't get validation errors fancy
fancy pants hello world nice to see you
yeah I could save it Wow
a database backs widget fantastic did
that in about what 10 seconds
not even which is pretty cool we also
it's a nice log output here but let's
actually look at some of this code what
actually happened there most of the
stuff that you're interested in is going
to be in actions your actions folder and
here is the actions app folder by the
actions app this is where most of your
life lives in a buffalo application you
create a new buffalo application give it
a few configurations by default we have
two different types of buffalo
applications automatic and standard
never use standard it's a stripped down
version of automatic and I don't know
why you would use it but we have it just
because we had some middleware like the
session saver so we automatically save
your sessions so you don't have to keep
doing it in your code anymore parameter
logging CSRF middleware kind of all set
up for us
I like to wrap all my requests in a
translate database transaction you don't
have to internationalization handler
asset handler and then finally our
widgets resource right down here at the
bottom so all that was generated for us
by buffalo by their generator commands
but you own this code and that's
important to understand
this isn't like Goa or something like
that where you have to keep continually
regenerating stuff once you Jen it
that's it we're kind of like here is the
base for you to work with this is your
application not ours do what you need to
and if we look at the widgets think
spell widgets we just go here we go this
is the action this is the resource that
we generated you can see here's some
nice list information so we go we get
all the list we have pagination set up
for you by default
paginate all your widgets but you go in
here and you change this and you do this
you build your business logic we're just
trying to get you started we want you to
have that beautiful win remember we want
you to start getting too busy getting to
your business logic as fast as possible
and giving you as much information as we
can to do that and you can go through
and you can see all the other fun stuff
that's happening in there then we have a
widget model somewhere if I can type
here we go here's my widget model that
was generated you you IDs you can use
int but I recommend you you IDs I think
they're better for a lot of reasons
we've got Auto manage created and
updated apps for you there's our name
there's our body so my string stuff a
collection type we even try to that
start adding validations for you based
off what you typed in that command line
because you said that you wanted to what
a title and our name in a body and you
didn't say there were no types so we say
okay well they obviously have to be
present that's where those validation
errors came from and then you could go
down there's different validations for
different action types like if you've
saved it if you've updated it that sort
of thing and now let's look at templates
new here's our new page for our template
we this lovely form for helper here for
anybody familiar with rails this is the
plush templating library by the way
hands down the most powerful templating
system Brian's going oh yeah no other go
templating system is this powerful and I
really truly saying that not just
because I wrote it but that's part of it
hey it was named after an awesome song
from the 90s what STP series are formed
for for a widget and it goes to the
widgets path and it's a method type post
and we've got a partial support here if
we look at the form for it there we go
we got nice things like input tags and
text areas and all sorts of stuff and
this handles all of our CSRF all of our
error handling if we go back to say edit
a widget and we inspect
the HDL it's not do that lets do a view
source that's the thing view source the
people still view source maybe not know
right click on the page like it's Osho
page source not view page source no it's
still the same damn inspector I was lame
there we go and go away and there we go
that's what I was looking for just give
you an idea of the generated form you
see it's got IDs and methods and the
authenticity token there which is our
CSRF token someone I think it goes off
the screen and all that sort of stuff
there yeah so this is all built-in this
was all free for you to just go and use
and do with as you please but this isn't
enough Rick how much how are we doing
for time we've got 10 minutes someone no
damn thank you I'm just gonna keep doing
this till someone responds because this
apparently means show me the time I know
sign language that's not true at all
let's uh let's actually deploy I clearly
don't know anything about sign language
let's deploy this app and then we'll do
some more fun stuff with it hopefully if
we still at some time here so I am going
to use the buffalo Heroku plugin I know
and have you used this yet now and if I
do buffalo Heroku setup here we go it's
gonna start creating a Buffalo app or
app for me
set to go can go env2 production set a
session secret for me it's creating a
database for me
sending up SendGrid for me because
typically when I set up an app I want
all the bells and whistles Redis and
that sort of stuff I could have skipped
some of this stuff but anyway they said
this is an unofficial plugin this is a
plug-in by the way but I didn't want to
sit here and type all the stuff out
while you watched there we go okay so
it's set up
Heroku for me it's building my docker
container that was built that was
generated for me in Buffalo
and now it's doing yarn stuff for all
that javascript I've added it's linking
dependencies building fresh packages
it's sad it's like the D acid stuff
takes so much longer than the go stuff
and we're almost done there there we go
okay we are making sure we have all of
our dependencies we are building the
binary here now we're in the go Buffalo
build world here
I'm gonna build a statically linked
binary with a - - static flag there we
go it's building everything there are
all assets got built
production great now we've moved it into
Alpine music multistage docker here we
are pushing to Heroku hopefully pushed
come on come on Wi-Fi here we go we're
running our migrations on Heroku
remember this is actually all hopping
inside an alpha alpine container has
just my binary in it it has zero other
files there we go I've migrated my
database here's my database config it's
gonna open up my brand-new Heroku app
here hmm
look at that right wow that's pretty
cool and then I go to my widgets there
we go and I create a new widget and this
is all working just fine
fine that's an easy pleasant experience
for anybody um probably not the
experience you had trying to write a go
app for the very first time I've
generated a ton of code admittedly but
writing these code right in this code is
not that complicated
if we go back really quick to the home
handler here
this is a pretty good example of what a
buffalo handler looks like they're
really simple and whether you agree with
the a concept of them being simple or
not we can definitely take that offline
Florin and I had a law I've had long
discussions both online and offline
about this not being a kind of standard
go type yeah
standard go handler but the reason it's
not is because we want trying to make
this as easy as possible for everybody
absolutely it's dead simple possible for
new people coming in and this is as poss
as simple as we can possibly get it you
have a handler you take a context you
return an error and we will handle the
error for you we give you ways to handle
the error on your own and you can easily
plug in your own custom error handlers
but by default we've got your back and
if you don't believe me take a look at
the one you're with here we go on that
solace of production isn't it let's look
at this route shouldn't exist here we go
here's what an error looks like in
development mode for example so invalid
type for UUID that not a UUID i can
imagine that we could see the whole
stack trace here we could see what is
currently in the context of this request
what are we looking at what a parameters
did we get were there any form arguments
and what routes do we have because maybe
this is a 404 page so again it's about
development we are trying to make your
life as good as possible by giving you
as much information as we possibly can
as to what went wrong and why it went
wrong and yeah and then we've got we've
only got five minutes left so you know
I'm actually to stop it here and take
just five minutes worth of questions
there's so much more I can show you but
I highly encourage you to go but go to
go Buffalo die oh there's tons of great
Doc's if you're looking for a good PR
Doc's are always a great first PR the
blog blog go Buffalo die oh I've got
insane amounts of video blogging content
I actually have an entire twenty minute
video I need to post about writing
custom helpers and go that I posted in
the selection and we have our own slack
channel the Buffalo slack channel I post
it in the air the other day but it still
needs to go up in the blog so check that
out go to the slack Channel tweet me
i've got stickers by the way awesome
ashley mcnamara buffalo stickers and
magnets woo no one else is giving you
magnets people revel isn't giving you
mad
magnets bigos dock using your magnets
iris definitely ain't giving you magnets
they'll take your magnets I really
should have said that but uh no I didn't
mean to say BAE he he will take your
magnets no too far just a little bit
okay
okay so we got time for just like a
couple questions are there any questions
right here in the front so I could hear
you it is is there a MongoDB plug-in
back that is an excellent question
pop is does not support MongoDB
currently I would love it if it could I
don't know if it can or not however you
can skip pop and bring [ __ ] to the
table but you don't get is the
generators that we have won't work for
you however we have plugins as we saw
with the Heroku one if I do you know
Buffalo - - help I should have a couple
plugins here right plug-in tools for
deploying helpers I don't have any other
plugins right now so you could
absolutely right you could be the person
who owns the Buffalo [ __ ] plug-in that
supports all this stuff has nice
generators and everything hmm it would
be awesome because I'm not doing it
other questions right there not so much
question but could you just show us the
console working because I'm sure the
console is getting a big refresh we're
currently using library called Gore but
what do we have we have widgets right so
I can say you know models widget and
then models DB first there we go and if
I print off the widget there we go and
then obviously I can update the widget I
can do whatever I want with the widget
but yeah we've got a new console in the
works that's gonna blow this away and
it's going to also be standalone too so
you can
in your own projects not just Buffalo
projects but yeah big or you can
currently do that but we can't control
it programmatically and that's our big
downside with it but yeah this is really
cool
that's one of my favorite parts and so
many people don't even realize it's
there yeah cool I think we got one more
question time for one more
right over there wait for the mic thank
you Mike nice talk thank you how can we
collaborate what is the a feature that
you need to implement or something that
you wish you have but you don't have
time to do it
oh what's the fissure the feature
I wish we had but I don't have time to
do oh god I don't know there's a lot
we're not there yet we're not at one oh
and that's important to know I don't
have a good answer for you honestly
because there's a lot of things I would
like to see more database support MySQL
Oracle any of those things are always
awesome more plugins for deploying tooth
tools like GAE or other you know Asher
whatever like I'd love to see plug-ins
for that stuff but just on the 100 front
we're at zero nine three came out this
week we're not going to 100
anytime soon and that's not because
we're afraid but because we want to have
the same compatibility promise that go
has so once we hit 100 we are going to
stay with that implementation forever
well not forever till - oh but we don't
want to make - oh like three weeks later
right we want you to have stable
applications with that said Buffalo the
o9o range has been incredibly stable
between upgrades apps almost nothing has
changed that you've needed to tweak so
right now if you go from oh a 209 for
example there are some changes there but
they weren't even that steep actually so
we're definitely leveling off yeah cool
I think that's all I have time for thank
you very much come find me four stickers
and magnets